the probability of getting a perfect
bracket
is lower
than me getting a hole in one
getting hit by lightning more than once
winning the powerball and all of those
things together
this is doctor magazine you can call me
mike okay mike he loves basketball there
was a time i played and when my son
started beating me in the driveway i
decided tennis and golf were my sports
he also teaches a class at the
university of cincinnati business school
that's all about bracketology you guys
are going to be the committee choosing
your brackets this is a two credit class
that's offered to advanced
undergraduates and graduate students who
have had a course in probability and
statistics
but what is bracketology
bracketology is a science and we have a
combination here of descriptive
analytics
how do we describe teams predictive
analytics what's going to happen and
also prescriptive analytics what's the
best way to fill out your brackets
okay got it so his brackets probably do
well right i'm an expert in the science
of bracketology which doesn't mean a
darn thing in filling out the brackets
and winning your office pool i
definitely didn't win warren buffett's
billion so then what advice do you have
there's no question that bias affects
people when they fill out their brackets
the science itself shouldn't be biased
but filling out your brackets
will be based on lots of other things
from mascots to coaches names to
where you went to school and everything
else you don't have to
love basketball to do well in students
who have never seen a basketball game
wind up winning sometimes because they
just use the science and don't have any
biases at all
you